did you know philly residents eat 12
times more pretzels than your average
american
that's twisted
pretty salty
that doesn't work
well that's your fun snack fact for the
road and think of it as an appetizer to
today's philly installment of the doggy
bag
here to curate we've got a philly based
beauty expert and you can keep up with
her and design tips every day
on instagram at beauty for breakfast
please welcome dana oliver yeah
drew hello
so exciting that i'm the doggy bag but
guess what i've got a treat
for you
so it's from my favorite local small
business black home brand that i love to
shop for it's my go-to for beauty and
wellness products and you know what i
love most about martian maine is that it
has the latest greatest even the big and
small brands
that you know you may find in your big
box retailers are ones that you've never
heard of love it and
on the table here i've got one of my
favorite products it is their hair and
body butter and i can't resist the
butter by the way i read that this was
your favorite product and now we get to
try it you get to try it i brought
four yummy scents you have the sweet
sandalwood which has a nice warm musky
scent you have the nog champa which is
just you know trade me too you would
have to smell this oh you are gonna die
the sandalwood
and
[Applause]
smell smell smell them all oh my god you
guys and touch and feel is non-greasy
and what i love most about this product
is that you can use it from head to toe
dana you're such a beautiful woman
inside and out and we're so excited that
you would grace us with your presence on
the show i think your recommendation is
so solid martian maine looks like the
most extraordinary haven for beauty
junkies thank you so much it was such an
honor to be in this fabulous city today
and thank you everyone for joining us
here at love park and everybody
watching at home or on the go or
wherever you are we hope that we get to
see you again really soon and again
everybody who decided to hang out and
spend a little time today
thank you we know you could be anywhere
doing anything thanks for hanging out
with us we hope you have a fantastic day
now i'm gonna finish a sandwich
[Applause]
[Music]